if you put food in let's say an air
fryer yes what does that mean okay so
they are going to brown your food
fast because they're moving hot air
across and they're evaporating any
possible moisture on that surface and
the faster the wind goes the faster
you'll evaporate it the faster you can
get to the Browning can't live without
an air fryer I'm sorry it's amazing
they're wonderful
yeah they're really air toasters because
uh you know unless the the surface is
sprinkled with oil and then the oil will
fry the you know you can heat the oil so
you're you're still
oil frying but you're using air to heat
the oil to fry the food right but if it
didn't have any oil it's just a fast
toaster
exactly
you mean I spent 400 on a toaster yes
you did yes
yeah
you did indeed and